[Musik]
drei walliser in rom vor ihnen liegt
eine skurrile mission
[Musik]
die männer wollen hier die 500-jährige
leiche eines fast papstes ausgraben und
die alten knochen dann heim führen ins
wallis in der kaserne der schweizer
garde zeigt ein wandbild den helden
dieser geschichte
[Musik]
kardinal matthäus china
china war heerführer des papstes
schlachtross des papstes
er führte 12.000 eidgenössische seltener
in der schlacht von mariano ins jenseits
[Musik]
jetzt wir hier am grab steffen ebert
folgten regierungsstatthalter im goms dr
werner bellwald walliser historiker und
volkskundler und christoph rieder der
spezialist aus dem deutschen tal
die exhumierung an der pest andere
quellen sagen an dass sie vieles seinem
tagebuch hat china anvertraut dass er
selbst noch als kardinal drei töchter
gezeugt habe ja da ist noch etwas
fleisch am knochen
seit 500 jahren liegt china im vatikan
im selben grad wie papst hadrian adrian
start nach china und verfügte ins selbe
grab gelegt zu werden
aber oben drauf selbst dem grab sollte
klar sein wer das sagen hat china
unterlag nämlich hatte ja bei der
papstwahl um zwei stimmen
[Musik]
ja
rosig
der überschuss gab es auch mal so zu
bauen und ihr euch
aus
erst einmal in den urlaub schon gelegen
dank mit
[Musik]
niemand weiß wo die knochen sind
vielleicht in der grabkammer
der vatikan hat den wallisern die
bewilligung erteilt in der kirche santa
maria dell anima eine probebohrung
vorzunehmen
eine dna-probe der knochen soll die
professionelle exhumierung chinas
ermöglichen
monsignore brandmeier ist perfekt im
vatikan immer in einem versuch
ja ja aus der ewigen stadt in den ewigen
schnee ins combs nur matthäus china und
herbert volken herkommen in ernen auf
dem dorfplatz steht das denkmal des
kardinals dahin will herbert folgten
seine gebeine bringen und ein mausoleum
bauen
[Musik]
das ist auch zum schmunzeln
das ist wirklich eine mannschaft ist
immerhin obwohl hier immer friede dorf
geboren ist war wurde in solid geringste
moderne armee trier ii score bischofs
mit zakrzewski original er schmunzeln
muss man über die schiene sondern über
relevante forum der hilfe sagt doch die
meisten typisch wahl ist was der wieder
für idee hat wie er sie halt erstens
noch recht stark gläubig der großteil
formal ist nicht alle register und so
hätten sie gegenüber der vorfahrer wie
matthias steiner respektvoll
das machen wir nicht um ihn schlecht
machen sondern im sleep china paris
liebt schöne heimat menschlichem kantons
lebt
das wallis gehört nun 200 jahre zur
schweiz
doch hier gelten eigene gesetze
falcon konnte schon bei seiner wahl zum
höchsten walliser freimütig bekennen
geschützte luchse und wölfe abzuschießen
[Musik]
cvp politiker folgten kreuzt ein halbes
reporter leben eine fährte
vor 31 jahren porträtierte ich ihnen als
fischer gemeindepräsidenten der illegal
schneekanonen bauen ließ
sie machen sich gesetz teilweise selber
dass wir schon macht welche bedenken
dass wenn wir normal die läufer mit der
ganzen verfahrens schriebe abendblatt
kanton und so dass der masse will ist
offen für alle seiten
das ist also jetzt ist respekt vor dem
werk seite wird er jetzt die schnelle
und der strom kommt er ohne erlanger
ohne es längst radfahrer zu machen
seine berghütte baute er im
naturschutzgebiet gemeinde kanton und
bund verfügten den abbruch aber er ist
befreundet mit bundesrat ogi rente sie
mich begleitet eine hassliebe zu diesem
walliser schlitzohr weltberühmt wurde
folgender den aletschgletscher
[Musik]
vor 300 jahren wuchs das eisen
verursachte überschwemmungen die kirche
erlaubt sein gelübde damit der liebe
gott den gletscher zurücknehme das
geschah aber viel zu viel
man müsse das gebet bloß andersrum beten
sagte falcon
einige bauten die bevölkerung aus
die schweizer wertvoll ist wir hatten
somit der klima wir werden älter werden
die gletscher schmelzen und die warten
auf sie wieder wachsen
[Musik]
papst benedikt folgte falcon und
bewilligte eine umkehrung des gelübdes
seit letztem jahr bietet money fisch
andersrum
zurück ins wallis tief im inneren des
löschens dort wo jahrhunderte alte
mythen dem wissen vor der aussicht
stehen werner bellwald auf der suche
nach der verlorenen würde in einer
wilden talschaft
[Musik]
der abfall forscher ist studierter
historiker und volkskundler das haus
seines onkels hat der zum museum gemacht
kriterium museum löschen
das erste schweizerischen sperrmüll
museum
[Musik]
bei walz forschung untersucht sein und
vergehen die frage von jenseits und
diesseits
wie jenseitig ist das land von carina
china heute mehr dinge schweiz und
fribourg im buch zwar ließ sich doch
katholisch und schwarz das ist ob dann
immer so antritt dann von litern geht
erstmals ein drittel plant entwickler
regelmäßig und irgendwo sie jetzt darum
schon wenig ist auch vom katholischen
glauben beim wand list und haben immer
alles bricht und sagen wofür sperrmüll
und und zum museum ist ein beliebter
friedhof angestanden oder her will ich
das [ __ ] vier weil es doch nicht ganz
weg sind und dass wir das waren und das
verloren hätten künstler ließ konnten
damals die barbaren gut verstand und
ihrer mode war da würde ich sowohl das
niveau sank das halten und ließen die
auf dem krieg sie und hätte sammlung um
die exit here wunderwelt und in tod und
sein begleiter das parkieren peter
walter schaaf stehen wo wir es auch
nicht was drin ist und besitzt das
geheimnis und maxi der tote wal mit der
günstigen mit der welt geworden bleiben
und möchten ihn als mann stehen um
universums simulieren himmel oder im
bringt eher schwach wer die kg stand bei
moment ohne hier sind bin ich beruflich
sind
[Musik]
der altar versteht sich als gleichnis
für den aufsteiger matthäus china
steckte auf in luftige höhen 1 nichts
und von wo steigt er heraus oder steckt
er ab hinunter in die ewige verdammnis
auch ins nichts
[Musik]
so viele fragen
der oberwalliser knotenpunkt dreck am
simplon das einfallstor aus dem süden
der dom zu st peter an den felsen über
dem bahnhof etwas vom glanz der ewigen
stadt soll auch im wallis schienen
bis vor zehn jahren war die simple und
festung geheime armee sache heute gehört
der bunker gemeinte sie hat hier im
granit des best gepanzerte museum der
schweiz eingerichtet
bei einer bellwald ist seit zehn jahren
als kurator für das schweizer garde
museum beschäftigt
[Musik]
und bunker hat historiker bellwald eine
kleine wohnung und sein büro format aus
china geht es zum abschied natürlich
keine bilder mehr viel rum diary nicht
warum jetzt später gar zum tod als bild
geschaffen wie sie quasi zu ihrer
geblieben ist dem koordinator kommt dass
um ihn durch sein dass die verwechslung
dass die spanier mit der nun also und
das ist bitter so was geht die man im
stich ölbilder ältere aber die native
ich also in der populären verwendung in
warburg sieht ist dass china von
naturgeräuschen um oder unter sich zu
bilden wie musik entsteht china sein
[Musik]
mühlebach ein kleiner weiler im goms der
geburtsort von matthias china
[Musik]
herbert volken hat die letzten
eingeborenen aufgestöbert
die beiden kennen nichts anderes als
ihren kardinal der allmählich abstamme
geschilderten vorvertrag die
frühgeschichte und da der junge kam so
sagen ich aber vielleicht ist ja nicht
wahr
übrigens doch sein versuch ein fast
papst kommt nicht einfach so sozusagen
durch die hintertür auf die weltbühne
chinas geburt ein fingerzeig gottes
china kommt am tag von matej zur welt er
atmet nicht er schreit nicht die hebamme
gibt ihn auf ohne den onkel wäre nie zum
leben erwacht er beugt sich über das
lieblose geschöpf und bläst den rauch
seine hand mischung ins gesicht matthäus
regt sich matthias schreibt matthäi am
letzten so verklärt man mir die geburt
china mit der china genau ist geboren
dass wir diesen monat das erstmal damals
mit viel am persönlichkeit unitas edu
con i 2
harmonie base vor dem china also ist er
registriert und so das ist mit fehlern
das jetzt mit dem thomas blatter mit
fehlern
das nt zelebriert später in ihrer
biografie und also auch im motto vom
tellerwäscher zum millionär
die wirklichkeit ist familie vom china
gordon zwar mit sehen dunkle spritzer
vorgesehen ist ein bisschen vor dem
risiko das mit dem stück und sorgen aus
der klima 1000 schulen geld das er die
nicht schrieb das ist und bleibt der
nordsee in europa gezogen und also ist
tatsächlich sehr schnell sehr vitro und
die priesterweihe steht hier irgendwo in
einem koffer der die aromen stock vom 14
dass ich damals nicht passiert das mit
dem gsv ab
ammann im goms im bezirk wo herbert
folgten präfekt ist eine kulisse wie zu
chinas zeiten rindviecher ganze bunte
vögel leben hier
sie haben besuch des freien theater
oberwallis
sie sind auf der suche nach einem
schauplatz für ihr china projekt
[Musik]
regisseur heimann anthamatten und
schauspielerin carmen werner oben erste
text hallo materials china egal dass ich
schießen das ich im matthäus evangelium
das sind die talente energetischer
verkörpert er andere mehr wert ist als
gottgefällige ich finde das gesetzt
materials matthäus leider schon gehört
zum glück kann nicht winkend
gottgefällig auserwählt erhört erhöht
wird hat wird haben wird nicht wird
darin um die die sites im jenseits
göttliche dialektik satte ernte hätte er
den vater wurde bezogen bis zum jetzt
sind sie das letzte mal konnten die
bilanz wieder durch city 213 schweizer
das geht immer und die fette
moderne bis frau interessiert wo er zu
beschäftigt mit dem original sin wo in
der gegend der hypo geht sie nicht
begeistert
was spielt er ja ich finde die
verkörpert für mich jetzt die wahl das
ist das eigentlich ein großer maler sehr
wichtig ist sie für viele hundert jahre
aber ebenso absteigt finde ich dass ich
denke wir jede historische orte maschine
der zustieg historische figur sondern
der rest über 10.000 klicks triboox und
der xxx auf dem schlachtfeld
verschiedene gewinn kopf und mehr kultur
mehr maxima culpa meine schuld vergiss
meine sünden prüfe meine werte in meinem
zinseszins schenke mir lösung
das ist willi mafiosi oder war die
können liegt um lenker nach der ganzen
kirche und nach buttons mit inbrunst das
also ist das schöne an der ganzen
[Musik]
seit die festung nicht mehr in gdingen
der armee ist hat sich die schweizer
garde ihr eingenistet
in einer jahrzehnten wohl 1500 sind
schweizer sind welt genutzt die
schuhsohlen der semesterferien von einer
ganz europa avanciert sie wählen
der französische könig ralf cordes
schwitzen logischerweise tabaksteuer in
der welt
das sind oft die besten schlagen sie die
un als holzen trade macht es sehr
effizient
die bewaffnung die technik-branche
norbert und den ganzjährig reagiert das
ist damals in europa so machen das werk
zurück der alten eidgenossen eine
mischung aus hall gabel bajonett und
büchsenöffner siegreich gegen alle
europäischen ritter herre so dass
kardinal china ins träumen von einer
schweiz als großmacht hoch er ist
natürlich sehr bitter an geschick der
mensch sie mehrere sprachen geschrieben
denn aus bischof ist ja sowieso schon
bald licher für stück sie in allen
standorten von der maxi und ich schaute
mit einem homogenen region ist politisch
statik sie und steht auch sehr geschickt
sie und hätte ausgenutzt und die staiger
wechselt als oberste schlacht für das
ist für die kitas problem wenn jetzt
mittelalter nicht verstanden
damals sie stehen aber bis schon fast
stündlichen landesherr das ist der ist
schlecht fürs bischof ist automatisch
franz walter zuständig peter münzer
tragen und so weiter ideal oder religion
verhöhnt
jetzt ist wieder mal einfach die frage
was sind die ideale von religion
mariano luigi maria ski ist bauer und
metzger sein hof steht auf dem
schlachtfeld
dort wo die eidgenossen ihre träume von
einer schweizer großmacht begraben
mussten
im mittelalter hatten die
eidgenössischen söldner nahezu jede
schlacht gewonnen und dann auch noch die
lombardei und mailand erobert die
mittelalter was die alten eidgenossen
mit den rittern gemacht haben mache ich
heute mit den enden
[Musik]
labbadia der tiger nennt man hier die
schlacht von mariano
[Musik]
das schlachtfeld liegt vor den toren der
großstadt an den verkehrsadern in den
süden
[Musik]
zwischen autobahnen schnellstraßen und
eisenbahnlinien liegt die blutgetränkte
erde von median wie im januar ist 20.000
eidgenossen treffen mit hellebarden
langen spiessen ein paar gewehren auf
30.000 franzosen ihre armee ist viel
moderner enthält sich mit kanonen die
schweizer vom leib von 500 jahren am 13
und 14 september 1515 fand hier die
schlacht vom renner statt
[Musik]
diese zeichnung des basta künstlers us
graf ist ein augenzeugenbericht er war
selten auf der seite der artgenossen
unter matthäus' china ist grauenhaft
gemetzel lastet er den kardinal an
vom hohen ross herunter habe matthäus
china nach dem ersten tag als tausende
toten verstümmelt auf dem schlachtfeld
lagen eine fanatische predigt gehalten
der kardinal habe die überlebenden
söldner aufgefordert als märtyrer zu
kämpfen als gottesmann versprach allen
die auf dem schlachtfeld sterben werden
12.000 jahre fegefeuer einzusparen
[Musik]
mit ska luigi schlachtet gänse schweine
und pferde ab und zu fliegt schon mal
eng knochen davon aufs schlachtfeld auf
seinem acker lag schon alles tut der
schweizer den franzosen und kanada
[Musik]
und übrig bleibt gar nichts
im besten fall jetzt in der schweiz geht
es schlag kopfball geht seine erinnerung
gibt's eine glorifizierung aber das geht
so viel schlachter davon nicht viel
übrig blieben und für die china ist das
ein wendepunkt für den china ist
jahrzehnte lang schwarz gegangen aber
vor 15 15 christus wieder klappt ist der
abstieg
15.52 ständig china verraten die recken
die soldaten verrecken mit tod durch
regen und jetzt unter schluss achtung
stoß schuss nummer die man das
ordnungsausschuss wir so werden gehört
ein giftiger offiziere lokalen kennt nur
konsument
ein mutiertes bewohner im valle ammann
er ist klein bauer und bildhauer er
schnitzt eine masse matches gegen das
buch also garantiert natürlich berührt
haben wir daraus wie sehr das ist das
symbol das heißt materie nicht so
schnell schläger claire als ganzes vor
us währung nachdrücklich wies politik
zudem ganze thema dazu erklärt und wenn
halt irgendwann der punkt richtig
deutlich halt 15 rother und probiert
rebellieren eine autopsie des mag sie
das heißt dass auch jene war beherrschte
mit kukksi war der obrigkeit oder eben
hat er genug auch für china
zwei jahre nach mariano wurde auch ihr
gemacht die vielen toten auf dem
schlachtfeld und sein machthunger
verziehen ihm die häuser nicht mehr
china dürfte seine heimat nie mehr
betreten
ihr genehm
matschie und wenn jetzt von der später
die perfekt von gomez die auto
zurückkommen
auch das machen oder weil sich das mit
dem schönen nächste sondern perfekt wie
eine monstranz china hereingetragen in
der simplen festung sind gemeinderäte
fahren und ehemalige schweizer gardisten
zusammengekommen
der präfekt hat zum hochamt gerufen er
hat ein bildnis des kardinals nach
jahrelangen falschen eine messerspitze
amtshauses reißen können
china kommt jetzt in die schatzkammer
[Musik]
co2 der sepp blatter mag metall wenn der
nutzer sie periode sand ist von der fifa
er hasste sie aber vorläufig der
matthäus in beliebten größer und
illustrieren als ein job
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das denkmal des kardinals werften
dorfplatz nichts zu suchen und das jetzt
auch noch seine alten knochen nach
ernannt kommen sollen
das findet francesco walter unerhört er
ist aus der kirche ausgetreten und lädt
mit dem dorf lehrer zusammen
francesco walter veranstaltet
musikwochen ernen und politisiert in der
cvp wie herbert volken herzen kardinal
schafft aber die person ist helmes
umstieg auf die schiene ist ein
machtmensch die mimisch nachgegangen
es ist um geld gegangen ist für sie also
jenes lied wo mourinho um das sind 12
diese lied war geschlachtet wurde sind
wir einfach zu groß ist also das
personal will kann also jetzt das
mausoleum machen was mir an religionen
sich sieben stufen
wenn ich zeit die ganze geführt werden
das in aller munde verlieren das sind
das andere religionsgemeinschaft xii das
macht mich so ängstlich darum bin ich
wenn über gärten kirche in welbergen
sind frieden mit gott oder mit einer vor
deiner größe finden oder mit ihrer stadt
oder was auch immer das ist das gut für
ihn
aber das sollte für die allgemeinheit
geld das das mini persönlich gemeint
der profi will doch nicht von cisco
jeder kriegt der kirchentür schieber und
jeder dorf stritt und familie wieder
vollständig wie möglich tun
also ich hoffe schon und übrigens damals
töchter vor hält der kontrolle aber
feldherr und ringsherum sowie das ist
nicht nur als sie zu der zeit wenn er
glaubt ein paar jahre vorher und nachher
hat die die kirchlich und weltlich
gewalt möchten ist das liege nicht nur
an
also hat sich obwohl wir das immer hat
gar gewinnt kann er das durchgesetzt
mariano
hier muss es noch jahre nach der
schlacht scheußlich gestunken haben
20.000 leichen lagen herum
niemand brachte sie heim nur krähen und
wölfe stürzten sich auf ihre knochen
[Musik]
das jahr nach der schlacht sagte
schienen nochmal dahoam is dahoam mit
langem schlachter christa aber respekt
und achtung und ehrfurcht vor den
anderen verloren vor der 12 soldaten und
offizieren übrig bleibt hatte hat er
mich wahrscheinlich mit nun ja nur die
beste wahl ist das beinhaus in marignane
vor ein paar jahren fuhren lastwagen
absichtlich in die verwahrloste schlacht
kapelle mit dem ziel das ärgernis aus
dem weg zu schaffen
weit gefehlt
auf 500 jahr jubiläum hin haben
eidgenössische patrioten der
gesellschaft pro mariano das radio für
300000 franken restauriert
[Musik]
jedes schulkind lehrt mariano sei die
geburt der neutralität der schweiz ein
hartnäckiger mythos der heute von den
rechten populisten gerne gebraucht wird
als auftrag zur politischen abschottung
der schweiz
ja
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der rückzug aus mariano den ferdinand
hodler an die wand des landesmuseums
zürich gemalt hat bedeutete keineswegs
einen rückzug der eidgenossen aus dem
söldener unwesen
bloß dürften nicht mehr private die
krieger anwerben sondern nur noch der
staat für die nächsten 200 jahre waren
ständig 120000 junge schweizer im
dienste ausländischer herre und das bei
einer schweizer bevölkerung von bloss
600.000 einwohnern markus somm ist
streitbare historiker der ehemalige
aktivist hat biografien geschrieben über
general guisan und christoph blocher und
gerade jetzt ein buch zur schlacht
mariano die geschichte einer niederlage
gestemmt
wir wollen die zahl nach geschlachtet
der schiene ist eine finte wähler und
hat eine hauptmahlzeit ganze von mailand
und du sowas würde mir auch käfer werde
vor der franzose jetzt schon mit zu
gehen auch die staubige blut und den
schweizer franzosen sind da jetzt
schlechter sicht und den hätten
unglaubliche zug aus der stadt mailand
die schweizer sind alle einfach kein
teilnehmer gefragt und so ist die
schlacht ausgelöst worden
der erfinder von matrei aus china
die schweizer sind wir einfach auch noch
ist jeder macht teilwiese was er will
es wird zwar immer wieder abgestimmt
dass ich auch interessant das wird auf
dem schlachtfeld wird abgestimmt sind
bereits zurückziehe oder seinem rad
briefe oder soll man überhaupt mit der
franzosen einen ausgleich suchen
das ist schon sehr sehr demokratisch sie
oder anarchistische schauen grund warum
tweets oder in verloren will der
französische könig natürlich ist sie und
hält natürlich jetzt dass er viel
effizienter führen aus schweizer selber
gemachten eine möchtegern großmacht am
boden von den ns bergischen eroberungen
blieb unseren vorfahren nur noch das
tessin übrig doch auch ein verdienst von
matthäus china
ich glaube es ist eine wende
die vorhersage meist frau 1515 hält dies
durchaus möglich können sie das ist viel
viel größer wird das so groß macht wie
für die frauenkirche übertrieben ab
jetzt die richtigen war mit 1550 das
irgendwie verwachsen sich craxi tweets
bebte riesenland markus somm versteht
neutralität als verpflichtung zur
politischen separierung john ist ein
enger vertrauter von christoph blocher
und sein verbündeter in basel keine eu
zurückhaltung bei der uno und den
menschenrechten und landesrecht vor
volker richter beackerte schlachtfeld
von renault für und svp wahlkampf und
markus somm zieht parallelen zu zeit vor
500 jahren
[Musik]
wir sehen diese frage aber eine der
einig schon deshalb sie mehr bewiesen
dass michael aufstehen meine wichtig ist
auch dieses land verursachen müsse der
umsätze wofür ist was vielleicht in
brüssel beschlossen werde ich vielleicht
in frankreich weniger das problem wobei
das wäre bezweifelt dass die ganze
diskussion über treu und zeigt wie
schwer das dass ich alles homogenisieren
aber für schweiz ist es verliest ufer
aber was soll mir schweiz unterhalb
dieser grenze machen wo sie lebt
engagiert man es zurückziehen
also grundsätzlich jedes land wird sich
nach der feier fanden
[Musik]
markus somm sehr gut ja zurück von dem
classic die dieser biografie und blocher
biografie die ausgezeichnete idee wurde
überholt teile aber die dynamik aber
dass er dafür zählt das schweizer gross
wird man sich abschottet und der brücke
zu hält das ist natürlich totaler unsinn
nur in zukunft sondern tatsächlich
bewies das gros wurde zusammenarbeit
durch solidarität
jean ziegler ist neben sepp blatter dem
ausland wohl bekannteste schweizer der
soziologieprofessor war un
sonderberichterstatter für das recht auf
nahrung ziegler lebt in genf in der
stadt in der welt für eine schweiz der
humanität und solidarität steht sie doch
stolz dass die völker wo im jahren mit
220 das ewz uno-hauptquartier traurig
dass du menschenrechtsrat permanent die
schweiz wichtig die organisation ihren
aufsammelt un-sicherheitsrat dass sie
keiner kann besteht sieht auf 202
millionen millionen und millionen aber
gerettet zu sieben prozent finanziert
von der bundeskasse sieht doch stolz
dass anstatt in der weitsprung sein kann
zeigt ein vorteil internationale
solidarität und was man damit nicht
dienen die neokonservativen die hölle
geworden da das die musik krediten aktiv
im bundeshaus
[Musik]
ein letztes mal zurück nach rom
nun führen unsere examina touren durch
das bohrloch eine sonde ins innere der
grabkammer schwierig genug schwerer für
die jetzt vorliegt
das thema ganz so wild wie von doch was
wenn dein großer olympia so die modern
gesehen
[Musik]
das ist durchgehend
kann man tatsächlich noch knochen finden
und wenn ja sind es chinas knochen
bekanntlich liegt ja auch noch ein papst
auf ihn herbert volken wird die proben
für eine dna analyse in die
gerichtsmedizin ins wallis bringen
[Musik]
doch liegt der rettung kommt ja ja ja
monsignore brandmeier gralshüter der
deutschen kirche in rom bringt unsere
walliser auf eine neue spur
[Musik]
ich habe einen hinweis bekommen
der hat gesagt ja ja aber vielleicht ist
ja gar nicht mehr hier
und es gibt eben in sitten in einer ist
nicht die kathedrale großes
rettungskette die wurde renoviert und da
hat man unter dem altar den leichnam des
bischofs von dem er wusste dass er dort
begraben ist gefunden und dann eben
rätselhafte weise eine ganz schwarze
nackte männliche leise und man hat ja
jetzt was ist das unter eine lehrerin
die es dazu gibt ist was man den kindern
es um die zeit schon nicht mehr die
schweiz durfte im salzfass dadurch dass
schwarze hinauf gedacht um die in aller
heimlichkeit geschäftlicher städte
gestartet habe das heißt der müsste nach
sitten gehen
wenn man allerdings wenn sie dann nix
nix findet dann wie viele dieser sieht
in der spur auch noch nach na ja das was
dahinter vergaben hier finden gegen
sehen das habe ich mir schon ganz andere
sachen gemacht habe weil sie empfinden
kritisch in ihrer schweizer die ersten
porsche ein handschlag geld ja
[Musik]
in seeon in der kirche wo matthäus china
als bischof vom wallis wirkte trifft
herbert folgten die altertumsforscher
des kantons sie haben vor zwei jahren
hier ausgrabungen gemacht und sind
tatsächlich fündig geworden
zwei leichen eine davon ist zweifelsfrei
ein china
aber es ist nikolaus china der onkel von
matthäus der auch schon bischof war die
kirche steht auf alten römischen mauern
dort unten haben die archäologen die
beiden leichen gefunden
das ist unwahrscheinlich
und jetzt sagt sie das sei nicht wahr
dass das ist sicher das kann man
beweisen ja das kann man beweisen
für uns ist ganz sicher das jetzt nicht
dass ich sein keine es viel zu jung und
ich seit 14 jahren zeigt dass er im
neunzehnten jahrhundert geschehen ist
[Musik]
falcon mag nicht auf die dna analyse der
römer bochum warten
er sucht weiter dem china seine alten
knochen die ganze große der hosni csc
[Musik]
ich bin ja
die schöne latina grenze zu china
schlappe
[Musik]
[Applaus]